great thanks so I wanted to talk about
being a product manager at Google for 11
plus years and then my experience
starting my own company a couple years
ago and growing that to 200 employees
now and just some of my life lessons
more generally but first I thought I
would talk a little bit about what I did
at Stanford my time at Stanford so I was
a computer science major I graduated 98
and i entered Stanford I took 106 107
108 109 some number of those courses it
was great i became a stanford section
leader my sophomore year I then became
the TA for CS 198 so to them ta program
and it was great and I love computer
science and then buy me my senior year
it started to get really hard and some
of the like programming operating
systems classes we're fairly daunting i
was working extremely hard and i wasn't
sure I'd you guys still talk about the
duck phenomenon right so so here I am
playing frisbee right um Sanford was a
was great but there was definitely the
the duck phenomenon where on the sort of
surface level you're playing frisbee on
the oval but underneath you're paddling
really really hard and that was a little
bit of especially sort of the end of my
Stanford experience so let's see so some
of my CS 198 friends were Steph Hannon
who's now the CTO for Hillary Clinton
out of nationalized shared an office
he's now the CEO of wealthfront he was
best friends with John Lilly now partner
at greylock Mike Schroepfer CTO Facebook
Marissa Mayer just one of our friends
and so now looking back on my Stanford
experience I think that maybe some of
the reasons that that I was feeling like
oh I'm not sure I can really keep up I'm
gonna blame my friends right like it was
I think my friends making me feel like
that there was some you know it wasn't
competition is just a very smart group
of friends so I guess one of the things
I'm trying to say also is that your
friends 15 years later your friends are
going to be extremely they're going to
be you know
major parts of the economy really um and
you and professors to so stay in touch
with your friends and your professors
and this was something else I didn't
quite realize when I was at Stanford is
that in 15 years you're kind of the same
age as your professors I know that
doesn't quite work out and actually I
didn't graduate 15 years ago but um but
approximately your professors all of a
sudden are sort of your peers now and so
so stay in touch with a lot of my
friends has been obviously one of the
great things that i have taken from
stanford things that didn't exist when i
was at Stanford the d.school the gates
building big data Sprint's growth uh I
just sort of interesting just to look
back on this right so growth we only had
marketing and like it wasn't measurable
really and to me growth now is let's
look at our whole funnel and let's say
you know how do our sellers convert how
do our buyers convert let's measure each
step of the funnel and at the time we
just serve had marketing we kind of
learned how to put a big billboard up
and that was that was marketing I hadn't
heard of growth really and then the
final thing I'll say on I'm sort of
Stanford life was I having a degree
being a female in the valley with a
degree in computer science is wonderful
it opens all sorts of doors I've no
regrets about about doing that
especially from Stanford but I also
think it's important I see a lot of
people kind of getting this superiority
complex like I'm an engineer all right
um and I may see a lot of people also
who have a little bit of an inferiority
complex some of my friends who don't
have engineering degrees and and they'll
be saying well you know my BD guy will
be talking about he wants to do a
partnership with someone but in order to
do the partnership they need to talk
about their api's he's like I well I
couldn't possibly talk about an API
because i don't have an engineering
degree right and i think that's actually
also the wrong approach to take so I
have a degree in computer science and I
learn programming in Pascal and it
doesn't actually mean that I'm any
better equipped to really talk about
today's you know internet architecture
right so I think it's important kind of
take everything in context um and so I
graduate from Stanford didn't really
know what I wanted to do with my life
vaguely thought that maybe I didn't
think that I wanted to be a hardcore
engineer at this one I was like I was
had been kind of daunted by the end of
my senior year so I said didn't want to
be a successful business person so I
went McKinsey right out of undergrad and
then actually I went to a startup after
mackynzie and we I peeled in March of
two thousand the economy was going bad
so I ended up going to harvard business
school this is Harvard Business School
brings back memories for me my thoughts
on the Harvard Business School if if
it's interesting so business school was
really fun and it was good for my self
confidence so I'd sort of by the end of
steam rose I don't know whether I can
hang academically it's really hard and
business school was different
academically like it was i speak english
as a first language which is helpful and
and and and i know basic basic sort of
math statistics that sort of stuff i can
definitely do you know formulas in excel
so so business school is great on those
fronts one of the things i do you talked
about remembering from business school
one of the cases I definitely remember
is the used-car case and I'm now in used
car sales so I thought it was
appropriate to talk about this so
approximately what happens in this case
is you get paired up with a partner I
boom gets paired up one person selling
car one person's buying a car and you
negotiate the price for the car and
there everyone comes back then to the
class and talks about how they what
price they settled on and it's this huge
disparity but different prices that one
comes comes to a different different
negotiation and what I remember about
this is the guy who who who really
screwed his partner the guy who came
back he got the best value in the class
just by lying through his teeth right
and I remember that guy and that's what
stands out to me and I have no idea
whether I did well at all on this
negotiation but but that's what stands
out and the other thing so that's a very
distinct memory the other the other big
thing from business school the people
that I really remember are what we
called the Gunners you probably have
this at Stanford as well but some will
ask the quest
and the gunner raises their hand and
follows the professor across the room
like I've got the answer and the gutters
stood out in my mind very much so really
to to sort of get ahead in business
school you have to talk a lot and so you
you know you're so eager um but again
your network is so important so if the
people you remember from business school
are you know are the Gunners of the guy
who like one at the used car case it's I
guess my lesson is your networks really
important and sort of think think think
about how you're interacting with your
peers and so I use the HPS network a lot
like it comes up a lot whenever I'm
traveling I look someone up who's HBS my
year that's one of the things I commonly
do ho who can i visit who can i connect
with and I said it looks good on the
resume but then I put an asterisk and I
and I had to think about what looks good
about Harvard Business School on your
resume and I think there are a few
things so one I think it looks really
good if you didn't go to like a tier-one
undergrad school then you go to Harvard
Business School you've got Harvard on
your resume and I think that looks good
but you know if you went to Stanford
there's really no way to go up from
there right so so it's tough so that's
that that right there is kind of
difficult I do not get into GSB actually
so that's why I went to to HBS I and and
they think it also looks good on your
resume but a big caveat in Silicon
Valley for me right now is I do a ton of
interviewing and that's that's one of my
big jobs right now is growing our
company and interviewing people and so I
interview a lot of people from 2006 for
some reason I keep getting resumes when
people who graduated from undergrad in
2006 and if they went to business school
I count them as a 2007 graph I give them
one year I take away one year of
experience because I think that going to
business school for two years is kind of
like working in the real world for one
year and that's just my calculation I
know people do it differently but I you
know it's it's it's a good experience
but I think being out in the working
world I certainly learned a lot more or
I have learned more so again I graduated
and didn't go into business school
didn't
clarify for me exactly what is I wanted
to do next but here's Larry and Sergey
and so 2002 i graduated from business
school and i knew that i was eager to
move back to Silicon Valley so I was
looking to join a start-up at the time
Google is the largest place that I was
looking at and I ended up sort of
networking my way into Google as I said
Marissa and I were classmates at
Stanford so I had definite connections
to Google um so I was a the next size
right so a couple quotes actually I
wanted to to bring up I guess so one was
eric eric says something like if you're
offered to see on a rocket ship Eric
Schmidt CEO of cool or no longer sorry
chairman of Google if you're offered a
seat on rocket ship don't worry too much
about which seat and then josh reeves
who's the founder of Zen payroll said
something like if your think about what
startup to join find a start-up that's
got into place with people who you want
to become and I think both of these are
good advice I personally believe that
joining us start up one of the the best
startups to join is one that is printing
cash and like if you go to a startup
that is printing cash you will be bound
for success there is some part that sort
of the rising tide lifts all boats and
so that would be one of my best like
piece of advice is yes like jump aboard
that rocket ship when you find it
because it'll do great things and
actually this is my next point so I said
I was a successful product manager at
Google for 11 plus years and my question
is or my thought there is okay so what
does it take to be successful at product
manager meant for more than 11 years and
one huge answer to that is you have to
stick with it for 11 years and I think
that sometimes I interview people
especially kind of coming out of
undergrad and they are looking for
something extremely fulfilling in their
careers and I think sometimes they don't
quite realize that especially straight
out of undergrad there's a lot of grunt
work involved in the work
and ultimately you need health care and
uh and it's a job still right and so
Google is um everyone everyone always
asked me isn't google the greatest place
to work this was the question I got a
lot and definitely it is an amazing
place to work and they say you've got a
sushi chef and you've got a masseuse and
you take a helicopter to work and you're
met by your concierge on the hell of
pattern this that and the other right
and isn't it the greatest place to work
and you know there would be time someone
would ask me that I think my product is
currently five months behind schedule
and my tech lead hates my manager and I
have to go to work on Monday anyways
right and so you know there's there's
just a little bit of that I think Google
is is treats his employees extremely
well but you kind of have to stick
through things there's still gonna be
grunt work especially when you start in
or early in your career and you kind of
have to stick through you know the ups
and the downs and kind of you know
ultimately we don't keep writing that
bed rising tide and let's see what else
do I want to say about sort of the the
product management time I think I think
the other thing that's tempting to do
some times that I've seen is your
attempted it sort of Facebook phenomenon
where you compare your insides to other
people's outsides and you look on
facebook and you know everybody has
smiling kids at the beach and their
clothes are always clean and all that
and the truth is like you're looking at
your insides and you know your family
life and you've got you know oatmeal all
over the floor and I think that we do
that in our careers as well right so you
look at your company and how it's going
and you see some other company thing oh
that's got to be way better but actually
just kind of don't know what's going on
on the inside so is that was my
successful product management for 11
years required being there for 11 years
and I thought I also just talk a little
bit about what I did as a PM and and how
I've seen product management change in
different stages of product management
so a product management to me
and I think it's changed a lot but I
would sort of talk about prime
management in three main chunks of Prada
management where the first part of
product management is defining the
vision defining you know how do we fit
in to the market what is our addressable
market how are we going to be
differentiated so sort of traditional
like strategy exercises and then figure
out okay so that's where we're going and
then phase two is let's and this is how
I think about phase two for me was okay
so what products are we going to build
to reach that vision sort of what is the
MVP what is the minimal Viable Product
what is the one what does be to what is
sort of our roadmap there and this is
where when i was doing product
management we all wrote prds and a PRD
was our product requirements document we
wrote that and that was kind of our
three to six-month plan for what product
we were going to build and then phase 3
was execution and so phase 3 we've
agreed what we're going to build in
phase 1 let's make sure that we hit our
milestones deliver on time on budget
that piece of things and I found the
different people often played very well
in different parts of that the phases of
product I particularly like the last
phase when things are kind of
well-defined and we can go just execute
on on things but I think a lot of
product managers actually maybe think
that the sexier part is the upfront
piece where you're defining what's going
to be built and almost the the UI work
that I think is now often done by
designers design wasn't a big discipline
when I was starting my product
management work like the product
managers often did a lot of the design
so three of the the main projects that I
worked on products that I worked on for
many years I worked on the billing
system I loved working on Google's
billing system not an extremely sexy
consumer product at all but this was
google had to pass an audit and
essentially Google was a multi-billion
dollar company in 20 cent increments and
how do you close the books every month
at the
of the month when you're getting server
the the logs on servers are all over the
world and one server in Hong Kong is
down and it's been serving traffic for
Chinese users and Japanese advertisers
and one server's down how do you figure
out what you actually owe and are
charged or are owed at the end of the
month so I like that project I
transitioned into Google's access team
the access team started really a little
accidentally we were talking with gavin
newsom a friend of mine and I were about
municipal Wi-Fi and nuni Wi-Fi at the
time was a very new idea new technology
so that you could have multiple radios
and you could be talking to one radio on
a lamppost it could be talking to other
radios and essentially could cover a
whole city with his like free muni Wi-Fi
and we tried to launch this in San
Francisco and it just became my project
because all of a sudden it was 100 cent
of my time was trying to launch free
muni Wi-Fi in San Francisco and
essentially we had a bunch of people who
knew on my team and you a lot of people
who knew about like signal propagation
but we didn't actually know how to
navigate city government and it's a very
different skill set it turns out and so
we were shot down and did not manage to
launch muni Wi-Fi in San Francisco but
we did launch in Mountain View and then
that parlayed into other access
initiatives googles mission is to
provide access to information to to
everybody and we became our access team
became focused on getting people higher
speeds and lower cost internet access so
this became a access to spectrum so that
actually playing in Wi-Fi free Wi-Fi
wasn't a great way of launching a
reliable network so for all of you who
are thinking of fundraising at some
point in your careers I was trying to
remember I had to go to Google's board
and ask i believe is for four billion
but it might've been 45 billion dollars
which is a different level of
fundraising when you're asking you know
I think we need like five billion
dollars for this initiative and this was
to actually purchase spectrum and when
we were trying to purchase
bactrim the way you buy spectrum in the
United States is this very iterative
round-by-round process and so you start
by bidding like a billion dollars and
then each round which is a multi-day
multi-week process you have to maintain
your eligibility so you have to bid more
each round so each day we are entering
okay that's two point you know three
billion but let's make sure we've really
got the zeroes right like it was a it
was an exciting exciting process and
then we ended up working a lot i ended
up working a lot on fibre to the home
which is still a big initiative for
google launching gigabit ethernet
connection connectivity to people across
the united states and then this pivoted
a bit right at the end of my google time
into Google ideas which is sort of
Google's think tank although they like
to call it a think do tank with a big
emphasis on the do but it's it's sort of
Google's think tank focused on getting
access having people get access to
information where it's really being
restricted so my next slide so here I
was sent to this is Tahrir Square and
Egypt right at the beginning of the Arab
Spring and we are they are they the
government of Egypt has just shut down
cable TV they've shut down al-jazeera
which is actually where a lot of the
Egyptians are getting their news on my
right if I've got this correctly on my
right is someone from the Egyptian
military on my left is someone from the
police the two factions weren't agreeing
the military the police and Google is
trying to figure out can we help in this
situation like is there something Google
can do to help people get the access to
the information like these didn't know
what was going on on the ground no one
did and so one of the things we decided
to do was let's see if Google can start
streaming al-jazeera on YouTube let's
try just streaming 24 7 live al-jazeera
and so we came back to Patrick Pichette
was our CFO at the time at Google and
said you know I don't really know
there's a business case here it's going
to cost a lot of money
and do you think we could do it uh and
one of the things that he said that
really stuck with me was he said you
know I want you to think about Google as
half public company and half movement
and like we're here to like do something
good in the world right and that's it's
not just about making money and so we
ended up streaming al Jazeera on YouTube
ok so that's where I left off right
trying to solve access to information
freedom of expression big ideas at
Google and ended I ended up leaving to
start a used car sales company so so
that's where we are now and so I started
this company shift with some of my
co-founders are here in the room today
for a variety of reasons but one of the
reasons was there just isn't a good way
to sell your car right now and you can
if you have a car to sell you can post
the car yourself on craigslist and try
to get good value for your car and it
ends up being much more difficult than
most people think and or you can go to a
dealership and you actually lose a lot
of money going to a dealership right you
lose a few thousand dollars and there's
got to be a better way right and so I my
co-founder and our CEO he was telling me
this he was telling me this and I was
you know hearing him he worked at Google
uh and then I actually went to sell my
car myself on craigslist and I said you
know this isn't gonna be that hard I can
sell my car in craigslist and first
person who showed up like cancel the
test drive on me like he was going to
come to my house and he postponed and
you know just a mess of scheduling and
the next person was super creepy and
like you don't know like some someone
shows up at your house you're like I am
not sure what I'm supposed to get in the
car with this person or whether I'm just
supposed to hand him the keys and let
him drive away in my car I went through
a couple more test drive so I ended up
just giving up and selling my car at a
used-car dealer and so so thus began my
involvement with shift
but in order to well actually one of the
things that also happen was then I
decided okay let me really dig into the
numbers here let me understand how big
is this market let's talk me through
what are sort of the unit economics that
car max has you know is this is this
something that makes sense as a business
um and so first actually I invested in
shift so I as I said I was friends with
George our CEO and so I was an early
angel investor in ship which made sense
to me just as an investment but I
actually wasn't going to leave my job at
Google so Google was a really good place
to work as I said um and I was also i
think i just had my first child and so
google provides this amazing five-month
maternity package but I also kind of
felt like at Google I was doing a lot of
making decks to explain why we should do
something that really made sense we
should do and then I had to make another
deck to explain it to someone else I
wasn't actually getting to do as much I
wasn't really launching stuff as much as
I was really hoping but it was nice um
and someone summarized it really well
for me which is they said okay at a big
company when someone joins the company
and starts kind of doing your work
you're like whoa whoa whoa hey hey
that's my work look that's my vertical
that you know I've got that vertical and
someone else's unit that's my horizontal
I'm doing that someone else does he look
I've you know I was assigned to that and
then a small company someone joins and
starts doing your work and you're like
oh my god please start doing my work
thank you so much I've got way too much
going on and I think that that was a big
difference for me coming from google to
to shift was it was just a different
level of engagement and a different
level of launching stuff we're just able
to do so much so much faster so so i
started at shift actually when i was on
maternity leave I just started helping
out a little bit and then I just got
hooked like it was it was a it was
really exciting to be launching stuff
and it was also just really amazing to
have customers be so appreciative so
when I talk about shift now it's it's a
small enough world that people tell me
look I sold my car was shipped and it
was great
thank you so much and especially in the
early days of shift like I got to know a
lot of our customers and they were just
like look thank you for dealing with
this I've been meaning to deal with the
car in my garage I just didn't know what
to do with it so that was really
exciting and what I wrote here is a car
company with Google DNA and well Google
taught us a lot like every day at Google
they say like what are you doing for the
customer how is this better for the
customer are you providing a better
customer experience and I don't think
that the car dealerships up today tell
their sales people every day when you
think about this think about like is
this the best experience for the person
who walks in the door like make sure
that they walk away with a great
experience and I think that that's a
really important thing we talked a lot
at shift about like every car you sell
like would you sell this car to your
younger sister like make sure we're just
treating people with that level of care
so that just seemed like like a huge
opportunity um and then again choosing
shift is a lot is a lot like even more
than I knew it's about choosing your
co-founders to when you're starting a
company and so you know it's a little
like you know when you choose someone to
get married everyone talked about this
is like who you gonna get married too
but you you end up knowing their parents
you know their spouses like George our
CEO who's here in the audience like I
know what time he goes to bed I know
what time he wakes up in the middle of
the night because he often wakes up in
the middle of the night and started
sending me emails I know what time in
the morning he wakes up I pretty much
know what he eats for breakfast whether
he works out you know whether he's got
date night that night like it is really
a level of engagement so choose your
co-founders is also like choosing people
who you want to be in mesh tin their
lives right um and and it's a you know
do they have a stable home life like do
they agree with you on the hours that
everyone should be working so for us we
have a lot of our employees have little
kids so we're this extremely
family-friendly environment because a
lot of us have little kids and so people
leave at 6-615 and people often come
back online around eight or 830 but it's
um you know people say how do you make a
family-friendly environment and I don't
think it's easy to make it
family-friendly it's like you don't
actually know what it means like if a
lot of people have little kids it's
going to be a family-friendly
environment right so choose your
co-founders there we are so George is on
my left he's in the audience I'm
actually quite pregnant in this picture
but the flag is conveniently placed
stuff or my belly in that so so let's
see so talk a little bit about
fundraising so we started just with us
as co-founders and then we were I'd
already invested but we were still
trying to raise more money raised seed
funding and someone said okay you might
think that you want to go like find rich
people that you know in your network and
ask them for money but actually one one
piece of advice we got was look go look
for people who've written similar checks
so if if you go to like crunchbase
insights or one of these sites that
tells you about people who've written
similar checks and you're going to start
an online marketplace look for people in
San Francisco and Silicon Valley who've
written checks for 50k 100k to fund
online marketplaces and that person is
likely to be the sort of person who's
going to want to write you a 50k hundred
K check for your online marketplace now
the same person who gave us this piece
of advice also gave us advice on on
raising from Sand Hill Road so I don't
know whether this is completely true but
this is what I was told uh now copy of
this I've been at Google so I really
didn't know anything about raising money
from Sand Hill bro but what we were told
was okay take the fun size and / 50 and
then ask for that much money and that
was that was the the math and so they
said look they the partners uh you know
they don't want to be on tons of bored
so they want a fun like 25-30 companies
from their fund so but they wanted fund
25-30 but they want to have some money
so they want to give enough money so
they have some in reserve you know just
in case and then once you've asked for
that much money then multiply by 5 and
that's your valuation so I'm not saying
this is perfect advice but this is what
we were told right so it's none of what
I learned in business
business schools about your you know
cash flows and net present value and
this is oh just take the fun size / 50 x
5 that's that's how much you're coming
to her so anyways I thought that was
interesting um I also learned a bit
about just how c'n hill road works and
what my role is most vs coo so our CEO
George does this he had to lead this all
and I was very thankful that he got to
lead this all but there were intricacies
that I didn't understand so like you
meet one of the partners and that
partner becomes your partner right and
Emily Melman is also in the audience and
she is our partner from dfj and she is
fantastic but generally I don't know
that we actually met Emily first but
generally you meet one partner at a fund
and then that person takes you to the
Monday partner meeting in a sense and so
it's not always mondays but it seems to
be a lot of Monday partner meetings and
that partner sort of preps you for the
partner meeting and tells you they oh
they go through your deck and help you
get ready but if you meet some other
partner first it's kind of hard to
switch partners if you're not happy with
the person you first met so then you try
to go to the to the Monday partner me
and you try to do this with like five
people on one day to go to like you know
Sequoia and Driessen dfj Highland all at
once and we did a little bit of that and
George actually ended up taking a nap in
his car at one point in between the
partner meetings because it's it's a
kind of grueling day but we ended up
raising 20 million in our series a 50
million in our series b we just raised
at the end of last year from goldman so
okay so once you raise all this money
what happens you have to grow your team
and so I this is a snapshot of us I
think right after we raised our series
be and so I thought it might be
interesting to talk a little bit about
interviewing because that was then
became sort of my one of my main jobs
was interviewing folks so get the
interview was
was the first tip I have and the the
thoughts there are people who are really
persistent oven do end up getting an
audience and so you know at Google
there's very defined roles but at a
start-up you know one of my friends
calls me Adam Nash calls me let's say
and says hey I've got this incredible
friend you must meet him I don't know
what role you have but he is so good and
like you know I'm kind of inclined i
would probably take that meeting right
and so people you can get an interview
like don't lob in your resume but like
get an interview do love in your resume
then also have your friend make an
introduction to someone and then
continue to be persistent we have some
of our sales team are amazing sales guys
and like one of them I think launched
like a ten-point drip campaign to like
get an interview with us and he just he
just understood our models so well and
he kept thinking about our business and
kept lobbing in suggestions on how we
could do our business better and
eventually we gave him an audience
because he was persistent and he was
smart and you know this stuff that he
was emailing us was like point on like
good tips for our business the second
thing I would say is the recruiter is
your friend I hadn't quite realized how
much the recruiter really is your friend
when you're interviewing um essentially
we set quarterly and monthly goals for
everyone in the company and the
recruiter has quarterly and monthly
goals that are based on how many people
we hire for the most part and so the
recruiter is very it it is in their
incentive to make sure that you come off
on your best foot and so if you're
interviewing somewhere make sure you can
ask the recruiter just easy questions
like what clothes should I wear
obviously what sort of questions will I
be asked what about the people will and
meet like anything you can tell me
they're like if you don't want to meet
for six hours on one day and you'd
prefer to split that into two days talk
to the recruiter about that like that is
the recruiter is there to handle all of
that and then know the questions you'll
be asked so there's a couple questions
that we always ask we always ask why are
you interested in shift like you are
going to get asked that question and so
there's no reason you shouldn't be
really good at answering back
question and then what questions you
have for me is something I ask everybody
and so sometimes people have no
questions for you I'm like come on it
just it doesn't seem like you're really
that interested right and if you don't
have a question the question I would say
you should always make sure to ask is
know everything you can about the
financials if it's a startup maybe there
aren't going to be extensive financials
but you can ask a lot about I mean in
our case like ask about the unit
economics ask about the fixed cost
variable costs right because you're if
you follow my advice which is you know
find a company that's printing money
then asked about the financials is one
of the most important parts of really
understanding whether this is going to
be a successful startup and then
negotiate and don't worry if you're
protected that's still part of the
negotiation so sometimes George and I
will both meet someone we might reject I
might reject someone because they don't
share my view on product they sound too
much like they share George's view of
product so you might get rejected just
because you agree with the CEO and not
with me and I was the one who
interviewed you you know it's not
necessarily a reflection on anything
personal so interview a lot because you
get better at it and then don't worry if
you're rejected a lot because it might
just be you know you might be sharp you
just might be the wrong thing and then
if you really are convinced that that is
the place for you you can still a be
persistent right so I have people who
said look let me come work for you for
free for two weeks let me do a
consulting project let me be your summer
intern just hire me on as a contractor
and maybe he'll keep me so all of that
is still on the table especially at a
small company ok so I told you a little
bit about about what we do but let me
just tell you briefly about some of
running the company and what we actually
do so i wrote i have a career coach this
is me like i do think it's important to
take time aside to just think about come
take a step back from the day-to-day and
so that's what my career coach that
space for me is just I've reserved an
hour to think about the bigger picture
about two years into the job I did ask
my career coach what is this
o.o do so so what I learned actually he
said well there's many different things
that coo is supposed to do but he said
you know you're supposed to be the sort
of like the VP of Operations the VP of
miscellaneous and you're there to make
the CEO successful so I learned a little
bit about that but a lot of what I do in
these sort of maybe the VP of
miscellaneous is try to set up some
structure for running the company and so
we do 360s these are our reviews at the
end of the quarter that we do for
everyone on at the end of the year more
extensively and so we've just copied
Google's and I think that it's hard to
be at a startup if you haven't actually
been somewhere that has a lot of
structure that you can copy so we've
just copied google google spends tons of
time thinking about what are good ways
of setting your quarterly goals and what
are the good ways of doing reviews we
just copy all of that how to run good
meetings you know you take action items
after every meeting every meeting needs
its notes published with action items
and then at the beginning of every
following meeting you have to then
review your action items from the
previous meeting all of that get to yes
is really important this is just it's
easy to shoot down people's ideas and we
try to say look let's just find a way to
get to yes and then finally well not
finally it's a marathon not a sprint and
and I think this just applies through
all of life but you know it's you gotta
make it through for a long time and so
for me this means i get my seven hours
of sleep so at ten o'clock is like how
to bed at ten o'clock at ten o'clock i
say oh I'm done with my work and it
doesn't really mean that I'm done with
my work it just means that i'm going to
bed because it has to be something that
you can sustain right and that's you
know through through everything and then
set in the culture of the company two
things that I really care about are
sending a positive place to work I just
think life's too short to not have
people waking up feeling good about
coming to work and then winning so I
think it's also you know it's not a
positive place to work if you're not
actually winning
okay my next slide but things life can
be hard and I want to make sure I save
some time for for QA but these are just
my life lessons I stopped out of
Stanford my sophomore year stopped out
for a semester because things just got
too hard too stressful and I am so glad
that I then came back and I didn't want
to come back I'd gotten really depressed
I gained 40 pounds I was like just
didn't want to be seen didn't want to
get out of bed and I just had to keep
going forward and like that is just the
gotta show up tell the truth hope for
the best and just keep going because I
wouldn't have then had the next phase of
my life which was very positive if I
hadn't just kept going and ninety-five
percent of stress stress is
self-inflicted I don't know where that
comes from but I think it's so true uh
it which is like your stress is all
internal and you know I am out there
running a race or something i'm doing
like I've been doing races and I start
to feel bad at like mile three and I
start to think oh my god the next ten
miles are going to be horrible i'm
running a half marathon but the truth is
it's just in my mind and right now i'm
okay i can keep going right and just
remember right now I'm fine and so this
goes to the the 20 40 60 rule which I
love Heidi use this in her talk i'm
copying it but at 20 years old so first
off I'm much happier at 40 than i was at
30 then I was at 20 just the place that
i'm at uh but a 20 um you're so worried
about what everyone else is thinking
about you yeah it stresses you out and
at 40 you just don't care what people
think of you and at 60 you guys that no
one is actually thinking about you and
and I think it's so true like no one
actually wakes up and it's like I wonder
if mini gained 10 pounds no one else
wakes up thinking about that right but
it still stresses me out and and so I
like that advice do wear a sunscreen
don't do drugs do have babies these are
really important to me don't do drugs
like a lot of friends at Stanford who
were like the daily weed smokers and
they'd always something like it's not
addictive I just smoke every day and you
know what those those were not my friend
who were Adam Nash Marissa Mayer was not
like a big stoner when she was in
college right like I don't think that
the stoner half of like my friend group
actually really was able to realize
their full potential so that's just my
my two cents there and do have babies
and what I mean by that um those are
mine what I mean by that is not that you
need to have babies but don't don't feel
constrained in having babies if you want
to have babies have babies like there's
never going to be the perfect time and
so I have a startup i started my startup
I was totally pregnant my startup and
like we were just raising our series a
when I was about to have my second kid
and like you know what you can make it
work right if you really want to and so
I just want to say one last thing on
women in tech because I always get the
question so I'm not a big like
evangelist of like more women need to be
in tech as I said it served me really
really well my current mesh mission is
actually just to make tech and make
business kind of just a more friendly
place for women so just to have like
boardrooms and management meetings and
and Sand Hill Road stuff just to be a
little less aggressive like sometimes
I'll be in a room and it someone be
coming after me like what are the
numbers what are the assumptions I'm not
good in that environment um but that's
that I'm really thankful to the women
who have come before me and have helped
me out so Heidi and Tina for asking me
to be here Emily Melton thank you so
much for being an amazing board member
and like Emily sits on our board and and
and sometimes nudges me and says speak
up speak up and I do appreciate it and
so and then finally most of all to my
mother who's here in the audience today
and is my rock and I am so thankful and
that's it
so you have time for some questions and
if you could just repeat the question
sure so I have time for some questions
and I can repeat the question yes does
anyone have questions great um go ahead
more since I think about shift as you
guys are growing really quickly what do
you find scales well and what do you
need to localize oh so I'd say you know
as we're opening new markets what is
central in what is local and I think one
of the sort of premises we've tried to
operate off of is if it can be central
have it be central because it just makes
for a more consistent experience it
allows us to sort of control things more
so that's hopefully an answer to your
question yeah I was just wondering how
you've addressed investors concerns over
the fact that your companies and during
a pretty crowded marketplace sure so how
we address concerns about entering a
crowded marketplace I think it's
important to differentiate yourselves
right and I didn't talk a lot about the
shift model but our model is we unlike a
dealership where that has a physical
location we have no physical location we
actually come to the sellers house and
evaluate their car and then we bring it
back to where we do like a mechanical
inspection and then when a buyer wants a
test drive we bring the car to the buyer
so that's actually a fairly different
model and I think an investor's speak
they would talk about your moat but I
would say that that sort of operational
complexity is very different than just
selling a car online and a lot of our
competitors are sort of more like
e-commerce sites who are selling cars
online I would say that that operational
complexity is sort of our greatest
strength and greatest weakness but it
differentiates us for sure yeah all
right so I find interesting they worked
at Mackenzie and then at Google for 11
years I McKenzie you got to see the
insides of a lot of different business
stranded only for a couple of years and
then a Google you spent 11 years in one
business which do you think is more
beneficial to you as you created your
startup hmm so which is more beneficial
sort of the Mackenzie experience seeing
a lot of companies or the google
experience really just seeing a lot of
one company i don't know that i can
quite say one of the other so i'll just
tell you a little bit about my
experiences you can decide which sounds
more valuable to you one of the things
that I look for a lot when I'm hiring is
my ideal candidate or for a while we are
trying to hire someone with two years of
McKinsey experience in two years of
startup experience or one year of start
of experience something like that
because it really blended both and so
the thing that I love about someone with
two years of McKinsey experience is
Mackenzie has trained them in some of
the analytic strategic structured
thinking they they know how to look at a
market and and come back with some
insights they know how to look at data
and sort of pull pull through some some
analysis so I love the McKinsey teaches
you sort of the fundamentals of business
but i also like someone who's seen the
inside of a start-up knows what that's
all about and then it's like eager to do
it again for me at Google so I started
there maybe 500 employees at Google and
now they're more than 50,000 but maybe
when I left order of magnitude 550,000
and so I really did get to see many many
different phases of Google which was
extremely valuable and I liked actually
I very much liked seeing the different
structures that Google put in place so
it was kind of what I talked about just
how does Google think about doing you
know snippets and coordinating
departments and it was also very
interesting for me to see how it is
evolved both are extremely valuable
experiences I think a little mix of both
is is great I actually think that it
would be very hard for me to i wouldn't
go start a company straight out of
school I just don't think you've seen
enough but that's also me I think some
people have a different it's a different
personality type but I think that for me
seeing something else has given me some
foundation to then build upon
building a company uh right now we are
just just building a national company
yeah question in the back um so a couple
of three points you talked about when
you're at Google somebody said to you
that when you were in the Middle East
about it's all about making a movement
who was that person second of all how
did you find your career coach and lash
um Steve Blank talks a lot about that
people who work in start-up so we're
successful tend to have a very high
chaos specials that you can deal with a
lot of uncertainty can you comment
on that uh okay we so let me make sure I
remark okay so the first question was
when the woman was when we're doing
Google ideas and who said that that
Google this is Patrick Pichette who is
our CFO and so he's you know he's the
guy who's managing our the ghouls
numbers and he was the one who said
think about Google is like half public
company half movement and Annie and I
think that that's the google DNA right
is to really care about what we're
building not just because it's a
business but also because it's playing
an important role in the world your
third question was about startups having
a high level of chaos right and i think
that's kind of my point about pacing
yourself which is it is a huge level of
chaos and and it's a huge roller coaster
and that can be extremely stressful and
I interviewed a little bit i talked to
someone it was more of a coffee but she
she was saying something like I said you
know I'm not sure maybe I could join
your company she had a server a hundred
person start-up and she said oh you're a
domestic animal like you couldn't handle
the wild you couldn't go into the wild
the wild being a while of like a
start-up environment because I've been
to khushi been too cushy at Google now
is her her sort of full serve her
perspective on joining us start up what
was your second question your career
coach oh how do I find my career coach
so I think I mean I underestimated know
ok Emily melon is in the audience as I
said she sits on our board I
underestimated the value of really great
board members and also that they will
also kick your
ask unnecessary and so I do think that
if you don't have a career coach and you
need one your board will probably tell
you that you need one and they will
probably even make some recommendations
on who your career coach might be um I
think in my case I actually found my
career coach myself because I wanted one
but um actually my career coaches Steph
Hannon who's Hillary Clinton CTO when
the people from one of my Stanford
friends she's won my Stanford friends
and a really close friend of mine still
she recommended one of her friends as a
career coach so that's how I found mine
sure one more question yeah um you say
that in order to gain experience you
have to be at the same job or 11 years
cuz that's just like no way to build it
up and how did you start ah being able
to be passionate about name even that
you're doing these different roles but
you're still working for the same
company and you feel that you were
making at the friends and I mean I know
you're thinking in retrospective well I
was ready and now I'm 40 and then so is
it worth it yeah so the question was um
you know staying at Google for 11 years
a little bit of like how do you stay
motivated and and I didn't mean that you
have to stay at anywhere for 11 years I
did just mean that there are times where
you go through hard times and it's not
always my advice is not always to bail
during the tough times i guess and and
because especially if you can see that
it that it could be better and so you
know one of my things is like show up
tell the truth hope for the best um in
my household we often say smile and nod
sometimes and and I do think there's
just a you know if it's worth getting
through you know kind of suck it up for
a little while and and so it's not that
you have to stay for 11 years but just
realize that sometimes sometimes smiling
and nodding and just kind of getting
through that will let you come up and
see the the next high that that's coming
up so so so i'm i'm all about sticking
it through and and yeah good things will
come well that was fantastic so please
join
me in thanking me
you